[Musique]
vous
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et en attend
vos points de vue au choix faut-il un
troisième confinement c'est la question
qu'on se pose sur le site du figaro
depuis la mi journée vous pouvez encore
voter si vous ne l'avez pas encore fait
ou bien faut-il comme peut-être comme
semble le penser la majorité des
personnes qui ont déjà répondu un
confinement différencier et donc à st
assouplir à la verse dans certaines
régions et bien on en débat ce soir avec
vous et avec julie de vins de provence a
dit merci d'être avec nous grand
reporter au figaro magazine le figmag
qui consacre ce cette semaine un superbe
dossier à la légion étrangère est avec
nous avec vous aussi
adrien matou journaliste à marianne et
auteur de l'indispensable mélenchon de
la chute c'est aux éditions du rocher
vous avez vu d'ailleurs adrien le figaro
ce matin 69% des français qui pensent
qu'il existe un problème d'islam au
gauchisme en france et y est chez les
invités électeurs a soumis compense en
majorité qui a pas de problème ça
contredit un peu la thèse de votre livre
en fait mélenchon a eu la raison de se
rallier à la ligne islamophile contre
les laïcs ne sont autres que non parce
qu'il ya sans doute moins de
sympathisants soumis que quand j'ai
commencé à écrire mon livre c'est
peut-être que ça a un lien avec la
question d'heures alors effectivement ça
vous donne encore une raison de lire
justement votre livre pour comment on en
est arrivé là une majorité d'électeurs
insoumis justement plutôt sur la ligne
islamo gauchiste
le livre donc et aux éditions du rocher
il ya un autre débat c'est qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui il ça concerne philippe de
villiers et la plainte qu'il vient de
déposer il en veut à blanc caire vers en
castex de ne pas exempter les élèves du
hors contrat des examens du bac
vous savez que ceux-ci vous le savez
peut-être pas n'ont pas le droit au
contrôle continu comme les lycéens du
public et du privé mais ils devront
passer le bac à l'ancienne finalement
est ce une mise en danger de ses élèves
est ce une rupture de l'égalité eh bien
on en débat et on est obligé de retenir
adrien m'a tout justement pour pas
commencer le débat dès maintenant mais
on va revenir sur l'agronome grande
actualité de ce soir jules jean castex
pendant que je salue nicole les chardons
bleus qui nous rejoignent sur le site du
figaro jean castex va s'exprimer
une nouvelle fois 18h15 mon champ sera à
suivre comme toujours sur figaro live on
va éviter de spoiler spéculer sur les
annonces à moins que vous ayez des infos
pour l'instant mais pendant que est rien
moins que jean castex sache qu'il veut
faire aussi on va faire un peu de nos
esprits pendant que les français en tout
cas plébiscite mais confinement
différencier certains ont une autre idée
un déconfit cette fois ci ce serait un
déconfinement différencier en tous le
mois à tout le moins une levée
progressive de du couvre feu
c'est notamment le cas de c'est ce que
réclame notamment le député l ère des
côtes d'armor mac marc le fur qui a
écrit d'ailleurs une lettre au premier
ministre
on écoute monsieur le premier ministre
le moral des français est mise à rude
épreuve
le statu quo n'est pas tenable c'est
pour ça que je demande au premier
ministre d'aller au delà de 18h 19h 20h
ce n'est pas très exigeant finalement et
en tout état de cause on ne peut plus
supporter pour le moral de nos
compatriotes d'être enfermé dès 18
heures on peut libérer un peu les choses
dans un certain nombre de régions je
pense à la bretagne bien évidemment mais
aussi au sud-ouest où les taux
d'incidence sont faibles a effectivement
dans ces régions là le taux d'incidence
c'est à dire le nombre de 4 go vide pour
100000 habitants est inférieur
à cinquante vous le voyez donc là sur 7
sur cette carte que vous pouvez
retrouver également sur le site du
figaro est également dans le live texte
inquiets
juste au dessus juste sous ce player
c'est selon judith parmi les cent
soixante trois mille lecteurs du figaro
qui ont répondu à la question sur le
site hier +2 67% se sont dits favorables
à un assouplissement des restrictions
dans les zones les plus touchées est ce
que c'est votre cas oui non ils ont
raison mais moi je voudrais un
assoupissement général j'attends
toujours qu'on me prouve l'efficacité du
couvre-feu à 18 heures pour l'instant la
seule étude probante con et tu as été
faite par le chu de toulouse qui a
conclu non seulement à l'inefficacité
mais a des effets pervers puisque comme
chacun peut le constater les gens se
massent les des concentrations de
population entre 17h et 18h à la fois
dans les transports dans les magasins
c'est une gêne terrible d'un coup au
moral supplémentaires pour des français
qui n'ont vraiment pas besoin
c'est il faut absolument respirer il n'y
a pas il n'y a pas de proportionnalité
entre l'heure du couvre-feu et la
contamination
or tout le monde tout le monde les
confine istres qui nous gouvernent font
comme si c'était évidemment efficace
rappellent que lors du précédent
couvre-feu en ile-de-france 20 heures la
circulation du virus avait commencé à
baisser avant l'entrée en vigueur du
couvre-feu
ce qui ne les a pas empêchés de
dire avec des accents de trion vous
voyez bien qu'un couvre-feu ça va non je
suis désolé il n'y a pas de preuve que
ce couvre-feu à 18h fonctionne 20h même
pas mais je comprends qu'on évite les
interactions sociales donc on empêche
les gens de circuler les uns chez les
autres
je comprend pas en revanche qu'on n'ait
pas rouvert
les musées au moins les grands où il est
extrêmement facile de surveiller les
distances entre les gens d'autant plus
qu'il n'ya pas de touristes je comprends
pas qu'on ne trouvera pas les théâtres
les cinémas pour les mêmes raisons
l'état de tension la société française
l'état de déprime des français la
violence parfois on assiste à des
explosions de violence et une montée de
l'agressivité sont directement liés à
ces contrats qu est ce que vous êtes
vous partager ce point de vue assez
tranchées de judith avrillas est ce que
vous êtes partager le point de vue de
chardons bleus qui nous dit que
effectivement le finistère et tout
l'ouest sont relativement clean ça nous
permet d'ailleurs de saluer les
habitants de ces régions
je partage beaucoup de choses avec
judith notamment le point sur les
théâtres les musées les cinémas qui à
mon avis pourrait être rouvert si on
prend évidemment les précautions
nécessaires
alors ceci dit alors moi je suis pas
pour une ouverture généraliser je suis
justement pour favorable à cette option
de de faire un traitement différencié
selon les départements
c'est à dire qu'il me semble tout à fait
opportun d'assouplir les règles dans les
départements où le taux d'incidence est
très faible par exemple le finistère il
ya aussi je crois le morbihan il ya même
la façade sud ouest en général est
plutôt est plutôt épargné selon la sueur
sur la carte justement qu'il est payé
par le figaro ont demandé à tristan de
la remettre sur le player
on voit que c'est quasiment tout l'ouest
la façade ouest de la foule de ses
serres façade ouest voilà on voit qui
est le rouge le plus le plus clair voilà
alors ceci dit moi je ne serais pas
contre
alors c'est pas forcément un couvre-feu
effectivement parce que le couvre-feu
l'efficacité n'est pas prouvée mais je
suis favorable en tout cas je
comprendrais qu'ils aient des
restrictions sur les zones sur les
départements où le de l'enseignant c'est
le plus élevé ça pourrait aller jusqu'à
confirmer jusqu'à confiné certaines
certains départements ce qui se passe
pour le week end à nissan
voilà un nom est alors bas le week-end
pour le coup c'est vraiment une
conception où les gens existent pour
aller travailler de 8 heures à 18 heures
la semaine par contre tout le reste du
littoral donc pour empêcher
spécifiquement les gens d'aller se
balader en bord de mer dakar c'est
pareil c'est pour aller vous alors évité
bien sûr que ça et jusque là simplement
ces zones où s'ébat enfin en tout cas si
c'est s'est dit comme ça d'accord
apprécié la consommation de pissaladière
des anglais mais en tout cas alors ça ne
me choque pas dans les zones où le taux
d'incidence est élevé et où les hôpitaux
sont saturés qui est des mesures qui
peuvent qu ils peuvent aller jusqu'aux
confinement après la question clé c'est
qui prend la décision et qu'il assume
et là ça me permet vincent de faire mon
petit point jacobinisme bi hebdomadaire
qui est qui est de dire parce que vous
aurez la caricature qui va vous dire
les parisiens qui ne connaissent rien
décide de ce qui se passe dans le
morbihan alors qu'eux ils sont
complètement déconnectés c'est pas et
donc ils veulent imposer la même chose à
tout le pays
non
la cohérence s'est pas imposé la même
chose à tout le pays c'est on prend des
informations partout les informations
remontent de tout le pays et ensuite on
adapte la prise de décision au
territoire
par contre c'est la même entité qui
prend toutes les décisions c'est une
entité centralisée c'est l'état qui
prend la décision ces gouvernements et
on ne laisse pas les présidents de
départements au président de région et
c'est prendre la décision
pourquoi parce qu'il faut que ce soit la
même autorité qui prennent les décisions
et qui en assume la responsabilité
le problème c'est que si vous laissez
des prises de décisions locales mais que
c'est l'état qui prend la responsabilité
de ce qui se passe il ya une déconnexion
entre la prise de décision et la
responsabilité et la mort me lis ça
poserait problème
par exemple en ce qui concerne le
littoral méditerranéen
vous avez entendu comme moi les maires
des petites communes autour de nice se
plaindre que christian estrosi et
décider tout seul avec olivier ferrand
donc si tu de fausses concernant c'est
que c'est vrai parce qu'on se serait vu
vu les protestations sa part ça paraît
assez probable
et vu les réactions estrosi s'est
félicité de l' cette décision-là
beaucoup d'autres on prend le club
doubiste nord par exemple c'est pas du
tout eu ni de l'udc à villeneuve loubet
par exemple dont il se souvient en effet
pervers que ça quand même c'est à dire
que c'est facile pour un maire entre
guillemets de de protester devant ses
administrés en disant que c'est
scandaleux les mesures qu'on leur
inflige et quelque part il ya peut-être
des zones je parle pas spécifiquement du
cas des alpes maritimes il ya peut-être
des zones où des mesures sont
nécessaires et où les élus font un peu
de démagogie en rejetant la faute sur
l'autorité centrale qui font la
démagogie vous en avez dans les deux
sens bien sûr ça peut être dans l'autre
sens en disant vous avez des confits
nist démagogues et vous avez des
libérateurs des magasins tension alors
je dit il va falloir convaincre cet
internaute qui lui dit il faut être
intraitable sinon on n'en sortira jamais
alors je voudrais cet internaute
m'explique
sans doute est-il pour un confinement le
plus ferme possible et le plus
généralisée possible ce qui empêche
étant donné l'état actuel de la campagne
de vaccination qu'une fois l'éventuelle
confinement d'urt hermine et on ne
recommence pas avoir le virus se
propageait de façon accélérée ce qui
empêche que de nouveaux les réanimations
soit en danger de saturation étant donné
qui a pas eu
ali pérennes supplémentaires organisées
on bricole délit mais ces soins du linge
de lit mais enfin ça fait un enfant le
10ème édition depuis plus longtemps qu'à
monde
par ailleurs oui à chaque fois je
rappelle que l'italie qui avait aussi
des problèmes de saturation système
hospitalier dé a pas totalement réglé
d'ailleurs mais a quand même réussi
c'était en septembre à embaucher 15000
soignant est à peu près six mille
médecins
bon ce que les italiens font on devrait
être capable de faire je me souvient
olivier vers en disant il ya plusieurs
mois il ya des dizaines de milliers
d'infirmières diplômées qui n'exerce
plus parce que le métier n'est pas assez
attractives tout trop pénible trouve à
le payer
où sont elles est-ce qu'il a augmenté
les est ce qu'il à revaloriser les
salaires pour rendre le métier attractif
non alors je suis désolé mais une
campagne de vaccination qui patine
d'airé a toujours pas à la hauteur de la
situation
tout ça fait qu un confinement durée
exacte e mans le même résultat que les
précédents c'est à dire qu'il faudra
recommencer alors moi je dis non
voilà vous dit non c'est le cas
également adrien de cet autre internaute
qui répondait à l'internaute que j'ai
mentionnés pour faire objection à judith
cet autre internaute charmant bleus nous
dit je pense qu'il faut
tout rouvrir puisque malgré toutes les
mesures l'épidémie continue alors je
fais quand même une nuance entre
couvre-feu et confinement c'est à dire
que le couvre-feu à 18 heures n'a pas
n'a pas effectivement prouvé sur son
efficacité
ceci dit les expériences de confinement
quand il est respecté il a mon avis
c'est la principale différence entre le
1er et le 2ème confinement le
confinement quand il est respecté a
quand même des effets assez saillants
s'il est une ordure papa le confinement
mobile de confinement du renard est
d'aller travailler on ferme les écoles
voilà exactement la même chose
le confinement durant force est de
constater qu'il a des effets temporaires
alors temporaire et oui sauf que là
alors il n'ya pas d'endroits au monde où
ça va pas repris après sa part pris sauf
dans les endroits ont vacciné il quoi
j'allais venir voilà la différence avec
aujourd'hui - là pour le coup on n'a pas
la boule de cristal sur l'efficacité de
la vaccination mais s'il y avait un
horizon où on pourrait se dire on
confine un peu comme au royaume-uni par
exemple une confine ça va être dur mais
il ya une vaccination qui marche
là ça pourrait donner des perspectives
les anglais ont une date certaine et
lointaine ils ont commencé aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs a annoncé une levée des
contraintes voilà et ils ont une date
ils ont un horizon qui fin juin qui est
le 20 juin je crois et ils savent quand
est-ce que ça va durer nous si la
difficulté notre situation c'est que on
a l'impression d'être à vau l'eau et de
on avait l'impression s'améliorait la
semaine dernière puisque le rite de la
vaccination
rattrapé celui de l'allemagne on est de
nouveau en soi de s'écarter
question subsidiaire quid du vote ces
russes qui a été reconnu par une étude
publiée par le 27
extrêmement efficace on attend toujours
on sait pas parce qu'on continuera son
passé parce que ça exactement et parce
que comme dirait madame heures von der
leyen par exemple de l'europe
il semblerait que la russie donc de la
commission européenne
il semblerait que la russie et des
arrières pensiez géopolitique et quand
bien même
et quand bien même
une autre internaute
liao belle qui nous dit pourquoi qui
nous demandent pourquoi perdre son temps
perdu a parlé de des confiné des régions
après ces zones deviendront très vite
des zones très touché on n'en sait rien
on n'en sait rien je disais tout à
l'heure que et une part de d'enfumage
dans le couvre-feu à 20h à aller en
ile-de-france et dans la façon dont les
résultats ont été présentés on nous a
présenté comme étant dus au couvre-feu
des résultats qui n'étaient que la
continuation d'une tendance qui s'était
amorcée avant que le couvre feu tombent
alors soyons sérieux il ya aussi la
question des vu qu'il ya plusieurs
facteurs il ya aussi la question de la
remonter les températures qui fait que
vraisemblablement la circulation du
virus va baisser et on sera dur de
mesurer la part de chaque facteur après
moi et vous allez dans la théorie qui
dit que c'est toujours au printemps
c'était aux intersaisons que c'est là où
il ya les pics de moralité composera de
contamination d'autres mais on a juste à
attendre que toute violence qu'on freine
mais moi n'étant pas pour un
déconfinement généralisée j'apportais
communion c'est à dire qu'il peut y
avoir des assouplissements locaux je
prends l'exemple du morbihan où le
préfet a décidé que le port du masque à
l'extérieur était désormais plus
obligatoire c'est quand même autre chose
que tout est confiné et dire qu'il a
plus aucune contrainte nicole nous dit
d'accord avec judith moi j'habite à 300
mètres d'altitude dans un village de
6000 personnes au grand r je n'ai rien à
voir avec nice et alors cet autre
internaute
je citais tout à l'heure au début dit
pourquoi il était favorable à être très
strict sait qui on est incapable selon
selon cet internaute de respecter les
gestes barrières et il voit notamment
dans certains dans certains endroits
encore des jeunes qui sont à côté qui
alors plus à ra salvatore puis ça ira
moins les gens respecteront on voit déjà
beaucoup de gens avec les beaux jours
revenus avoir une sur tout à fait
relative du respect des gestes-barrières
ça ira en s'empirant en empirant pour
pour les raisons de d'acceptabilité et
d' atteinte au moral que je signalais
tout à l'heure c'est pas juste un petit
coup de mou on est dans un climat de
dépression chez les jeunes enfants même
les la société française de pédiatrie a
fait une longue note le 25 janvier pour
lancer l' alerte jamais il n'y a eu
autant d'urgences psychiatriques chez
les enfants les jeunes maintenant enfin
on s'en occupe tout le monde sait que
leur situation morale économique mais
morale et psychique est très très
vacillante continuons comme ça une
petite observation c'est qu'on parlait
d'israël tout à l'heure israël par
exemple à des à des mesures auxquelles
le président réfléchit pour l'avenir qui
sont par exemple le passeport vaccinale
qui serait nécessaire pour se rendre
dans certains endroits où la culture de
l'apport calorique traçabilité un petit
peu que certains jugent très intrusive
pour pour combattre le virus donc il ya
d'autres manières que le confinement le
couvre-feu pour combattre la circulation
mais qui sautent qui sont également sur
le feu en tout cas emmanuel macron lui
il réfléchit on a l'impression d'une
répartition des rôles en fait à chaque
fois c'est emmanuel macron qui essayent
de lever les contraintes ça a été vrai
qu'en exor fils de ted venir le tory a
été premier ministre et castex lui passe
derrière
on va d'ailleurs en savoir si c'est si
c'est le cas tout à l'heure donc lors de
la conférence de presse qui sera donc à
programmer appliquée à partir de 18h
donc dans une quarantaine de minutes
maintenant faut-il un troisième
confinement c'est la question qui était
posée qui est posée sur le site du
figaro vous pouvez continuez de voter
pour l'instant et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il ya près de 71%
de noms sur le site du figaro alors que
c'est avec ses bases et qui le fait
souvent souligné ce genre de les
réponses à ces questions étaient
habituellement inverse depuis depuis un
an et que considérablement le nombre de
partisans de confinement a baissé de
façon de façon régulière et ça suffit ça
suffit on va passer à un autre
un autre sujet si vous voulez bien ça
quoique un peu connexes ça vous a
peut-être échappé mais il y aura deux
formes de bac cette année si vous avez
des lycéens dans le public ou dans le
privé son contrat et bien fini l'épreuve
dans un centre d'examen c'est le
contrôle continu et en revanche si vous
avez choisi leur contrat ou de passer en
candidat libre là il faudra passer à
l'ancienne si j'ose dire dans un centre
d'examen avec notation par d'autres
profs que ceux du lycée alors dans le
figaro les figures de proue du hors
contrat montent au créneau dans les
prochaines heures notamment hervé
rolland le président de la fondation
pour l'école ou encore anne coffinier
président du réseau créé son école et
ils ont reçu un soutien celui de
philippe de villiers qui porte plainte
en justice contre véran castex et blanc
caire et il a expliqué notamment
pourquoi sur le site de boulevard
voltaire je reproche à cette décision
d'être des frais minatoires au plan de
l'égalité des droits est dangereuse sur
le plan de la sécurité sanitaire pour
les élèves de france qui n'en ont pas
droit au contrôle continu et qui devront
se présenter en présentiel comment dit
maintenant nous à une nouvelle longue
ovation pour passer le bac
alors s'il ira la course et c'est inédit
est ce qu'on pourrait appeler le bac du
cocon le bac protéger le bac distant
ciel sondés sur le contrôle continu
on les lycées publics
et il y aura de l'autre côté le bac
exposées au vide pour les écoles
indépendantes qui n'ont pas de droit qui
n'auront pas droit au contrôle continu
vous dites est ce qu'il ya un paradoxe
ce fils de villiers a demandé un bac en
contrôle continu que l'étonnant de
l'exigence scolaires dont on pourrait
penser que c'est le cas de philippe de
villiers estime moins exigeant que le
bac avec épreuves en centres d'examen je
connais pas les positions de philippe de
villiers son contrôle continu dont je
peux pas répondre à cette question sur
la discrimination il a évidemment raison
c'est pas la première fois déjà l'an
dernier jean michel blanquer a essayé de
faire le coup pareil levée de boucliers
il a reculé
il n'y a aucune raison que les élèves
soient traitées différemment je repense
à la phrase de david lisnard le maire de
cannes qui dit que l'état étant
incapable de réprimer l'abus limite les
usages la on a l'impression que parce
que l'état est incapable de réprimer les
les dérives si vous voulez des écoles
hors contrat toutes sont soumises à un
régime d'exception je parle là de la loi
séparatisme on est on est plus sûr
strictement street aux stations schuman
mais on al'impression vraiment que
toutes les écoles hors contrats sont
ciblés que le bus est désormais rld et
le plus possible quel que soit leur
activité et leur nature alors pour elle
dans ce que vous dites enfin il ya un
internaute qui dit que c'était
l'occasion rêvée
2 il ya longtemps quand nous dit élan
qu'il voulait se faire leur contrat kato
est ce que c'était l'occasion rêvée
c'est le journaliste de marianne alors
bon dans cette affaire il ya invite
d'ailleurs les gens à lire l'interview
de philippe de villiers
alors je crois que c'était valeurs
actuelles et boulevard voltaire où il ya
quand même beaucoup de victimisation de
voilà de d'exagération et une forme de
communautarisme mais qui semble plus
acceptée par certains sur la question du
bac alors en réalité c'est vrai que
instinctivement on pourrait
effectivement quand on voit qu'il ya
deux bacs et que c'est différencier sa
question je vous posez vous esquivez
nier qu'il ya une rupture d'égalité
alors il ya une rupture d'égalité
je m'amuse de voir des gens qui la
combattent en permanence et égalité
républicaine la halle invoqué pour pour
être outré de ce double traitement
d'autant que mais peut-être qu'on en
reparlera l'existence même des écoles
hors contrat est une rupture d'égalité
en réalité mais c'est un autre sujet moi
je trouve que c'est justifié pourquoi
que sont les écoles hors contrats des
écoles donc qui ne sont pas des écoles
privées sous contrat attention à leur
contrat c'est une part minoritaire des
écoles privées et qui en fait se sent
bien montré aucune subvention de public
mais qui en contrepartie on la liberté
quasiment totale dans leurs modes
d'enseignement
il ya juste un socle commun de
connaissances mais qui quand vous le
regardez est extrêmement mis en réalité
c'est vraiment les bases des
connaissances des connaissances pour
pour vivre en société qui sont demandés
pour le reste est totalement libre et en
fait quand on comprend ça on comprend
pourquoi c'est impossible de faire du
contrôle continu
parce que il ya une enquête très
intéressant de 2002 2016 de la cabine
versailles sur les écoles hors contrat
qui en fait avait montré que ces écoles
là
transmettez le socle commun minimal en
français et en maths par contre il ya
les énormes différences sur toutes les
autres matières et en histoire notamment
dans le cas des écoles religieuses
qu'elle soit catholique musulmane ou
autre les cours d'histoire et de
sciences de svt sont extrêmement
différents alors je vais être un petit
peu caricatural et provocateur peut-être
à dessein mais en fait on ne peut pas
accepter qu'un élève et 17 en histoire
en contrôle continu
parce qu'il a écrit que pétain a sauvé
la france je vous dis pt1 sauvé la
france je le soir
mon chapeau les tests c'est un rapport
de versailles c'est à dire que c'est des
choses qui existent
je sors 1917 innocenti oui alors là on
parlait de seconde guerre mondiale le
cas échéant voilà est ce le crois que
c'était il y avait aussi c'était en
c'est dans cette école des traîtres qui
ont fui en angleterre je prends un
exemple caricatural mais c'est juste
pour vous dire que si on voulait faire
du contrôle continu pour ces écoles hors
contrat ça demandait ça demanderait des
contrôles extrêmement poussé pour chaque
école hors contrat pour vérifier que
c'est dans le cadre plus large de
l'éducation nationale donc c'est un
petit peu normal de faire la dhr et
lorsqu'on sera sa conscience
quinze mille candidats non non les 8
candidats bacheliers par en plus les
dirigeants 5,9 dans leur contrat haut de
gamme quelle ville bacheliers inscrits
mille candidats bacheliers plus les
10000 qui veulent passer le bac après de
l'enseignement en distance non je suis
désolé ce ne veut pas dire des contrôles
absolument aberrant moi je suis pour le
renforcement des contrôles des écoles
privées hors contrat de toutes
confessions a bien sûr parce que je suis
tout à fait choqué que d accueillir
d'écoles confessionnelles dans leur
contrat william payet a vanté sourire
aux écoles musulmanes et aux cathos
tradi un petit peu mais il ya tout le
reste aussi la montée serait figé ce que
je suis pour les contrôler également
mais que l'état fasse correctement son
boulot de contrôle au lieu d'instaurer
une inégalité à la fin du parcours ça
c'est pas normal vous pouvez pas
contrôler le contrôle continu
dans ce cas là c'est plus que l'année
dernière c'est ce qui s'est passé mais
dans ce cas là c'est plus deux écoles
hors contrat en fait non l'an dernier le
bac a été donné comme ça à tout le monde
enfin donner le tout le monde trahi par
l'aps beaucoup de succès au bac seront
va dire l'an dernier mais
devant devant le tollé jean michel
blanquer a fait marche arrière et les
écoles privées hors contrat ont obtenu
d'avoir le contrôle continu comme les
autres il n'y a pas eu de drame absolu
après ceci dit on peut élargir le
constat c'est moi je suis contre
l'existence il vous demande si vous
auriez mixte aline à sauver la france
non non je ne pense pas que c'est pas
parce qu'on pense que pétain n'a pas
sauvé la france en 1941 qu'on pense que
ça l'est il a sauvé ses leaders c'est un
petit peu symptomatiques des réactions
épidermiques des partisans de l'école
hors contrat qui quand même fond et
toutes les enquêtes font état de dérive
extrêmement inquiétante à tout les ans
plusieurs dont quatre pour le vous ceci
dit moi moi j'assume pour le coup je
suis contre l'existence de ces écoles
donc effectivement voilà par principe
donc je pense pas qu'elle devrait
exister je pense que le privé sous
contrat à toute légitimité
mais que le on dénonce beaucoup de
séparatisme et là on invoque l'égalité
républicaine l'existence de ces écoles
est une est une entorse à l'égalité
républicaine
c'est à dire que c'est une fuite des
gens qui ont les moyens qu'ils ont
beaucoup de moyens
ou alors qu'ils sont vraiment prêts à se
sacrifier financièrement parce qu'ils
veulent leurs enfants une éducation qui
soit différente de celle des autres
pas forcément il ya des écoles privées
hors contrat qui sont très peu cher et
d'ailleurs qui attire une partie de
public très modeste parce que au
contraire parce qu'il est décontractée
structuré qui ont des grands financiers
de rire des groupes de voleurs c'est pas
un match que j'encourage ben oui mais
enfin allez dire ça allez dire ça à des
parents qui n'ont pas les moyens et dans
les dents les enfants sont coincés non
justement une zone ou l'oubli
les lycées publics sont très mauvaise
qualité justement rendre ça j'allais
venir parce que c'est effectivement un
bon argument parce que on peut pas
demander on peut vu qu'on peut éviter
d'en accuser les gens qui sont contre
l'école hors contrat de forcer les gens
à mettre leurs enfants dans de mauvaises
écoles publiques mais alors ceci dit moi
contrairement aux défenseurs de l'école
hors contrat
je ne défendent pas tout ce qui fait
qu'on détruit l'école publique depuis 40
ans c'est à dire que dans ce sujet là
c'est vraiment c'est un peu comme avec
la sncf c'est à dire que on coupe pour
pour moi il ya deux mots qui touchent
l'école publique il ya un mot qui est le
manque de moyens le fait qu'on met plus
d'argent dedans et il ya leurs finances
des pédagogistes je pense qu'on sera
d'accord sur un sur deux et moi je vois
là c'est très facile de détruire tout ce
qui fait l'école publique et ensuite de
dire elle ne fonctionne pas dans ce
scandale
je me tenais enfants leur contrat à mon
avis si on investit 700 ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe sur que dans
les enquêtes qui ont été faites et qu'on
a été faite au figaro c'est que ce qui a
fait le succès du hors contrat c'est
justement l'échec et la faillite
merci non seulement du privé du public
et d'une partie du privé sous contrat
oui alors ceci dit nous on appelle pour
ce qu'elle a fait c'est à dire que une
école hors contrat qui sélectionne ses
élèves qui choisit comme elle veut c'est
les élèves qui la composent
elle a forcément de meilleurs résultats
qu'une école publique et dans une
moindre mesure qu'ils écoles privées
sous contrat qui peut aussi sélectionner
ses élèves
donc c'est un petit peu face au ca de la
vente par des critères de sélection sont
c'est à dire cela mais une école
publique pas par définition ne savait
que vous pressez ses élèves donc c'est
un petit peu facile de venir encore une
fois casser l'école publique parce qu'on
a vraiment cassé depuis 40 ans et
ensuite de dire regardez comme ça marche
pas par contre le privé hors contrat qui
n'a pas du tout les mêmes contraintes
marche beaucoup mieux c'est un petit peu
facile quand je vais vous surprendre
non seulement on est d'accord sur le les
méfaits du pédagogisme d'ailleurs je
pense pas qu'on puisse accuser les
partisans de l'école privée hors contrat
deux débats devant du bolide d'après de
la presse et d'apprécier le pédagogisme
mais je suis même d'accord sur les
moyens à condition de dire qu'il ne faut
pas plus de profs il faut moins de profs
beaucoup mieux payés oui alors moi je
mettrais plus de profs mieux payés je
pense qu'on y avait 35 élèves par classe
même un excellent prof a du mal à faire
très bien sur ce qui s'est passé le
témoin et pour le coup je pense que
beaucoup de profs vous diront qu'à un
certain nombre c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils disaient adrien tout à l'heure
sur le fait que justement on accuser on
pouvait pas accusé
si je vous suis le public de déchets qui
après m les élèves dans leur contrat
parce que c'était il y avait deux poids
deux mesures et que dans leur contrat
ont pratiqué une sélection est ce que
vous êtes d'accord exploiter ou pas
évidemment qu'on pratique une certaine
forme de sélection dans leur contrat moi
je suis pour la sélection et je trouve
qu'on devrait la pratique et y compris
dans l'école publique mais pas en
rejetant des enfants qui sont pas au
niveau mais en faisant un enseignement
beaucoup plus différenciées en venant
vraiment à bout de l'égalitarisme en
mettant les gens qui ont les mêmes
difficultés plutôt ensemble plutôt qu en
les répartissant dans plusieurs classes
pour que ça soit moi l'expérience prouve
que quand on veut comme quand vous
faites ce genre de répartition le groupe
qui a le plus de mal tire vers le bas
tous les autres écoutez je pense qu'on a
eu tous les points de vue qui ont été
tes pas d'accord il ce dernier point est
échangé j'imagine plus de vacances pour
les profs
et pour les élèves je laisserais que
cette semaine de cours par en faire 10 %
du programme mais du bon et exprimez
vous dit romain plus des coûts plus je
pense afflelou plus de vacances de plus
de vacances n'est pas parti et voilà
c'est pour ça que l'on vous on vous
invite c'est pour vous ouvrir des
perspectives manche et adria et l'on
nous dit que la scolarité alors
apparemment dans certains établissements
hors contrat c'est 100 euros par
trimestre et par enfant
c'est parce qu'il ya un mécène dernières
finales à la seule idée reçue et vous
pouvez avoir des tarifs ils sont
supplémentaires par exemple dans le
privé sous contrat est dans le succès se
dit dans dans le privé sous contrat
c'est dans le succès beaucoup plus oui
dans le succès quand il ya par exemple
non dans les enquêtes qui ont été faites
par le figaro sur sur les en tout cas le
succès rencontré par leur contrat il ya
aussi le fait que dans certains
établissements privés pour certains
parents en tous les cas ils ont le
sentiment d'avoir la double peine parce
qu'ils payent des scolarités qui sont
finalement assez élevé et ils ont les
pour avoir pour avoir le même
enseignement que quasiment dans le vide
donc c'était pour justement verser au
débat en bretagne il ya 50 % privé ce
n'est pas cher nous dit élan mais pas de
renaître à met pas dehors compte my hand
à dia dur oui il ya 50 % des écoles n'y
a pas de 50% des colons hors contrat en
bretagne ont posé la question sur sur
twitter pour savoir si vous compreniez
la plainte de philippe de villiers
contre le gouvernement sur le
baccalauréat de vitesse et une légère
majorité enfin une majorité une petite
majorité de oui à 56%
merci beaucoup d'avoir un grand merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci de nous
avoir suivis par mois pour les certains
problèmes qu'on a rencontré ce soir sur
le chat du figaro mais vous avez pu
continuer à chat et on n'a pas pu
prendre le chat youtube en est désolé
mais vous inquiétez pas demain on
arrivera à le prendre et à vous citez
vous continuez à nous regarder de plus
en plus nombreux toujours sur la
plateforme sur la chaîne du figaro et on
vous retrouve donc à 18h ce soir pour la
conférence de presse de jean castex et
demain même heure même endroit avec
guillaume roquette a très vite sur
figaro live
[Musique]